لا يعول على الشعر في تغيير الحياه
والمجتمع ولكن لان سؤالي انه حتى لدى
النخاب النخب عندما يقراون نص في الكثير
من الزاني لا يخسر بعض المعنى يعني هذا
النص يعني ما بدي يضرب امثله يعني
الدهني يدمر
عندما تشتغل على القصيده فكريه ومعرفيا
لان القصيده الجميله الموفقه لابد ان يكون
فيها ماء كما يقول النقاب العربي
ان يكون فيها ماء ان تكون جميله خفيفه
سلسه فيها لمسه ثانيه
وفكريا لا تصبح شعر اخر خطوه العقل في
القصيده تدمر شعريه الناس
في النهايه الشعر ويضر بمنسوب الشعريه في
القصير او ربما من اجل زالت يمكن محمود
درويش تسرب كثيرا يعني همم كان منتشر همم
هذا الماء هذا الماء
محمود لانه رحلتي عن الاحياء يعني
لكن ايضا لا ينبغي ان
نعتقد ايضا ان
القصيده عندما ترقى الى مستوى معرفه
معناها ضروره ان تضعف هذا يعود الى موهبه
في الابداع وفي الملامسه العمق الجمالي
القصيده هناك شعراء كبار على مستوى
الانسان
نجحوا كشعارات كبار مؤثرين في المجرى
الشعري الانساني لانهم ايضا نجحوا في
العثور على معادله بين الجانب المعرفي
والجانب الشعري
للحياه للحياه الغنائيه
نعم مثلا في شعر محمود درويش اساسي مهمه
جدا لكن ايضا هناك تجارب شعريه ارتقت
بالقصيده الى مستوى ميتافيزيقي والكثير من
نماذج الشعريه الانسانيه الكبرى كانت من
هذا النوع من الشعر
وجودي وليس فقط